moi je vais vous emmener pas dans
l'espace mais peut-être dans l'espace
temps
une orgie de données que vous allez voir
défiler là dessus parce que je suis un
maniaque des données je pense que quand
on regarde les situations à travers les
données on peut faire des projections
sur l'avenir qui sont extraordinaires
avant de commencer je vais vous faire
travailler deux secondes je vais vous
demander de lever la main ceux et celles
qui dans la salle crois que nos enfants
vont vivre mieux que nous lever la main
ceux qui croient que nos enfants vont
vivre mieux que nous c'est pas mal parce
que vous êtes un petit peu papa en
majorité en tous cas ceux qui sont
optimistes mais vous êtes une proportion
importante mais je peux vous dire que
dans toutes les salles où je demande
c'est habituellement la minorité des
gens pensent que les ans leur enfant
vous vivent mieux que mieux que nous ça
veut dire que on est des sociétés si on
pose la question à des adultes aux états
unis ses 85 % des gens qui pensent que
leurs enfants vont vivre moins bien que
on vit donc dans une société qui qui qui
ne croient pas à l'avenir ou qui a peur
de l'avenir et peut-être avec raison que
je vais sans tenter de vous montrer
certaines choses parce que la vitesse
des changements dans le monde est
absolument fabuleuse et puis cette
vitesse des changements
elle a tendance souvent nous faire peur
et on n'a qu'à penser par exemple
perséphone choses et je dis tout le
temps
il ya 20 ans dans le monde c'est une
image que j'ai emprunté à un collègue du
new york times il y avait dans le monde
trois états unis c'est à dire trois fois
300 millions de consommateurs qui
consommait comme vous et moi 900
millions de consommateurs et si vous
vous souvenez durant les années 90 y
avait toutes sortes d'organismes sur la
planète qui disait qu'on ne réussirai
jamais avoir les ressources pour faire
répondre aux besoins de ses 900 millions
de consommateurs b regardez ce qui s'en
vient dans très peu de temps d'ici dix
ans selon toutes les évaluations sur la
planète et certains disent que je suis
même conservateur il y aura dans le
monde neuf états unis 9 x 300 millions
de personnes qui consomment comme nous
regarder en chine par exemple deux fois
300 millions il ya déjà 400 millions de
chinois qui consomment comme nous c'est
un dynamisme fabuleux pour une société
aux états unis avec leurs 300 millions
de consommateurs ils sont devenus là
première puissance mondiale vous savez
quelle sera la prochaine puissance
mondiale le regarder l'inde regarde et
l'amérique latine au tour du brésil
c'est la plus grande transformation
économique de l'histoire de l'humanité
en termes de vitesse et de proportion et
on est passé aussi sur la planète
maintenant on ne parle déjà plus du g8
mais du g20 à une transformation
politique ou si extraordinaire parce que
le pouvoir s'en va ailleurs
et on dit que c'est la plus grande
transformation qui s'est produite et qui
ne soit pas le résultat d'une guerre ça
c'est intéressant un changement de
pouvoir dont qui s'est fait regarder
l'importance en terme de deux produits
intérieurs bruts que va prendre l'asie
au cours des prochaines années regarder
l'afrique aussi l'importance que
l'afrique va prendre au cours des
prochaines années en termes de
concentration de pouvoir la chine sera
bientôt la première économie on dit que
la n va a devancé le japon très bientôt
en 2020 50 % des chinois vont gagner
entre 15 mai les trente mille dollars
par année vous savez que le salaire
moyen aux états unis et de trente quatre
mille dollars c'est pas si élevé qu
salon qui s'en viennent les émergents
contribuent déjà à 80% de la croissance
mondiale un milliard de nouveaux
consommateurs viendront des pays
émergents d'ici 2025
et malgré tout ça ce que je vais essayer
de vous démontrer aujourd'hui c'est que
nous si on y croit on peut profiter de
cette croissance là et avoir notre place
malgré la peur que peut-être peut nous
inspirer ce développement la regarder
aussi l'importance que prendront les
classes moyennes dans le monde émergent
en termes de proportion atteint sur la
planète
regardez la classe moyenne chinoise et
la classe moyenne indienne par rapport à
la place qu'ils occupent aujourd'hui
dans le monde
regardez l'importance relative aussi qui
va diminuer pour nous en terme de deux
pouvoirs et d'individus riche on aura
plus du tout le monopole de la richesse
l'occident va perdre beaucoup
d'importance dans le monde en proportion
avec ce qui s'en vient
les pays qui montent sont des pays dont
on dit qu'ils ont du carburant
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont des croissances
moyennes plus élevé que bien plus élevé
que nous mais surtout c'est des pays qui
ont la plus pour la plupart des
populations extrêmement jeunes comme on
l'était nous dans les années 50 des
revenus
os donc ce qu'on appelle du carburant et
regardez les pays qui intéresse les
banques d'affaires le plus en termes de
croissance dans le monde
la variété de ces pays-là bangladesh
toujours avec les données que j'ai
évoqué plus tôt corée du sud egypte
indonésie mexique nigeria pakistan
nigeria 160 millions d'habitants
on prévoit que d'ici 20 ans ils vont
être 300 millions d'habitants en afrique
les philippines la turquie et puis le
petit vietnam en bas c'est un c'est une
c'est une idée des pays qui monte qui
s'en viennent parce qu'ils ont du
carburant les entreprises aussi vont
beaucoup changer le portrait des
entreprises dans le monde va beaucoup
changer regardez bien parmi les 500 plus
grosses entreprises de taille mondiale
en 2027 venaient des pays émergents
d'ici quelques années
230 vont france vont venir des pays
émergents c'est à dire 46%
parmi les entreprises qui ont un chiffre
d'affaires de plus d'un milliard par
année il y en avait huit mille en 2012
dont les trois quarts étaient issus du
monde développé regardez ce qui s'en
vient en 2025 qui va s'ajouter 7000
entreprises dont les trois quarts vont
venir du monde émergent et ce quelle
honte particulier ces entreprises la
pensée à alibaba ceux qui connaissent
alibaba cet immense firme de commerce en
ligne qui est qui a commencé à naître
qui est né en 1998 elles sont plus
agiles ces entreprises là du monde
émergent parce qu'elles sont nées dans
un contexte difficile récent mais aussi
parce qu'elles sont plus disposés à
investir allemand alors au terme parce
qu'elles sont jeunes
contrairement aux entreprises vous le
savez aux états unis qui paralysent
l'économie américaine parce qu'elles
n'osent pas investir leurs réserves dans
l'économie parce qu'elles ont d'une
certaine façon un peu peur de l'avenir
comme beaucoup d'entre nous on a peur de
l'avenir d'ici 2030 les marchés mais
alors tout ça bien sûr va avoir des
conséquences sur l'environnement je
voulais dit tantôt cyan on s'inquiétait
des 900 milles millions de consommateurs
il ya 25 25 ans les regarder ce qui s'en
vient d'ici 2030 les marchés émergents
vont contribuer à 80 2 % de
l'augmentation des ventes d'otor 56 %
des ventes d'avions 65 % de la demande
en énergie
si tout ce monde-là consomme comme nous
on consomme on arrive à une impasse
absolument terrible c'est pour ça qu'en
chine actuellement on est en train de
penser à électrifier les transports
individuels de façon massive au cours
des prochaines années la demande en eau
si on continue à consommer à au rythme
où on consomme à 3,7 milliards de
consommateurs dans le monde 3 2 pardon
la demande en eau sera 40% supérieure à
l'offre
la demande en pétrole 30% supérieure à
le gaz ça serait la même chose bref il
va falloir des trouver des solutions
pour l'avenir et c'est urgent je donne
toujours l'exemple du chocolat quand on
parle de ressources et de consommation
regardez la consommation du chocolat en
chine par habitant par année 100 g
au brésil deux kilos en suisse 11 kg par
habitant par année
si les chinois ne consommer que comme
les brésiliens pas comme l'est pas comme
les sus il consommerait à eux seuls
l'ensemble de la production actuelle de
chocolat et c'est comme ça avec les
ressources c'est comme ça avec tout en
plus on s'en va vers un monde qui va
complètement être à l'envers par rapport
à tout ce qu'on a observé dans le passé
jusqu'à ya dix ou quinze ans la majorité
de l'humanité vivait à la campagne
aujourd'hui plus de 60% des humains
vivent en ville ils étaient 17 % à vivre
en ville en 1950
imaginez la mutation en chine il était
630 millions à vivre en ville en 2010 et
en 2030 ils seront 1 milliard ya 120
villes de plus d'un million d'habitants
en chine dont on connaît atteindre les
noms regarder chez diageo en bateau
djobo des villes qui naissent à une
vitesse absolument faramineuses regardez
la population des mégapoles mégapole qui
se bâtissent dans le monde comme
shanghai et tout ça d'ici 2025 2025
cédantes dix ans donc c'est des défis
d'urbanisation absolument fou des défis
pour des entreprises comme bone
structure par exemple qui vont qui vont
qui vont fait qu'ils vont avoir des
opportunités absolument incroyable parce
que dans toutes ces villes là qui
naissent de façon absolument écouter
dans le monde ya 1,2 million d'individus
qui déménage en ville chaque semaine
c'est la plus grande migration de
l'histoire de l'humanité on dit que dans
les 600 villes les plus grandes du monde
et les plus importantes en termes de pib
va s'ajouter 130 villes au cours des 15
prochaines années et seville avons
presque tout venir de chine ou en tout
cas d'asie en particulier à imaginer le
défi d'urbanisation alors que nous par
exemple dans une ville comme montréal ça
fait 25 ans qu'on se demande s'il faut
recouvrir l'autoroute ville-marie en
chine devant shanghai on abattit si vous
êtes allé la ville de pudding un des
plus grands centres financiers et
manufacturiers du monde où aujourd'hui
on détruit des tours de soixante dix
étages qui ont été bâties il ya vingt
ans pour les rebâtir tellement tout ça
va vite et tout ça se développe c'est un
défi encore une fois absolument immense
pour nous c'est des opportunités aussi
immense
il ya tellement de progression dans les
pays émergents qu'en asie seulement il
ya 5,5 millions d'étudiants qui
cherchent des places dans nos
universités parce qu'ils n'ont pas ils
n'arrivent pas à soutenir le rythme et à
produire des places dans les universités
les entreprises voulaient dit tantôt des
marchés émergents investissent deux fois
plus que nous dans la croissance
ils auront besoin et ils ont besoin de
nos produits
et si on est fort en technologies de
pointe comme on l'est et si on est
audacieux en termes de d'ouverture au
monde et d'aller voir les marchés et
bien regarder les opportunités qu'on a
parce que pour résoudre les problèmes de
croissance qui se produiront surtout
dans les pays émergents
les sociétés émergentes aurons besoin de
nos aoc pour l'instant encore ce que
nous avons si nos gouvernements cessent
de désinvestir en éducation et continuer
à investir ils ont besoin aussi de
créativité et c'est une autre de nos
richesses qui profitera de tout ce qui
s'en vient de cette croissance là
amusons-nous encore avec les chiffres
dans les prochaines 8 secondes 34 bébés
vont être dans le monde 5 en inde 4 en
chine un aux états unis
de quoi aura l'air le monde pour ces
enfants là on parlait nos enfants tout à
l'heure quelle sera la première économie
du monde
on parle de la chine d'ici quelques mois
à peine
quelle sera la plus grande armée du
monde l'armée chinoise est la plus
populeuse mais n'est pas encore la plus
performante mais ça s'en vient ils
investissent des fortunes
quel sera le centre financier de la
planète la concurrence est encore très
ouverte en pour l'instant c'est encore
les centres additionnels qui aura le
meilleur système d'éducation au monde on
vantait les états unis il ya quelques
temps qui était au sommet de la pyramide
à cause du désinvestissement massif sous
la période bush aux états unis les etats
unis sont rendus 13e dans le monde
le canada étant est encore parmi les
trois premiers ce qui est très important
très bon investissement
quelle sera la devise la plus forte
c'est encore pour l'instant le le dollar
qui aura le plus haut niveau de vie
il ya toutes sortes de changement de ce
côté là aussi il y avait un pays et ça
vous montre à quel point le monde a
changé il y avait un pays en 1900 qui
avait tout ça et c'était quel pays
c'était l'angleterre évidemment alors
vous voyez à quel point aujourd'hui ont
un pays ne peut pas monopoliser tout ça
parce qu'il ya une concurrence
absolument ferrasse quels sont les pays
qui vont avoir la plus grande croissance
dans le monde regarder les exemples
récents sierra leone mongolie qu'on
appelle mangrolia bien sûr deux pays
pauvres mais qui ont des ressources à
revendre quel sera donc le continent
après l'asie qui rendent croissance
fabuleuse pour les mêmes raisons
l'afrique qui va prendre une importance
inouïe
mais malgré tout ça et là c'est encore
quelque part où on peut avoir un rôle où
on peut avoir une
une façon très importante d'intervenir
c'est que malgré tout ce que je vous ai
décrit on se retrouve encore aujourd'hui
avec des inepties sur la planète comme
par exemple qu'un enfant sur trois dans
le monde émergent ne complète jamais une
cinquième année 2 milliards d'êtres
humains n'ont pas accès à l'eau potable
encore aujourd'hui malgré tout les
développements 1 milliard ne mangent pas
à leur faim 1,8 milliards n'ont pas
accès à l'électricité
il ya cet habitant sur dix en afrique je
vous ai parlé de l'afrique qui va
décoller qui n'ont pas accès à
l'électricité imaginez vous ce que ça
veut dire pour l'éducation des enfants
et cetera et cetera
donc c'est un défi immense pour la
planète un défi dans lequel on a on peut
avoir une contribution aussi importante
pour vous donner d'autres images un peu
absurde
il ya 600 millions d'indiens qui ont un
cellulaire aujourd'hui au moment où on
se parle en inde
mais il ya 600 millions d'indiens qui
n'ont pas accès à des latrines ans il ya
eu de la journée des toilettes récemment
qui a été lancé par un milliardaire
chinois qui qui est qui investit dans le
domaine et même bill gates a investi des
centaines de millions de dollars dans
l'invention d'une toilette économique
pour résoudre ce problème qui est un
problème de santé publique
inwi si vous êtes allé en inde même dans
les grandes villes comme délit les gens
font leurs besoins dans les parcs et
c'est un problème très dangereux 80% de
la population dans les pays émergents
sas une donnée qui m'a été fournie par
le mouvement desjardins n'ont pas accès
à des services financiers de base au
mexique
c'est 75% de la population mexicaine
d'accord notre partenaire donna dans
l'alena qui a pas de compte en banque
mais imaginez encore là le développement
possible pour nos institutions
financières par exemple qui ont l'audace
d'aller là bas c'est donc un pari de
développement pour tous si un pari qui
se résume dans des choses qui pourtant
nous paraissait élémentaire qu'est ce
qui va pouvoir développer dans le monde
pour que tout le monde croise de la même
façon qu'est ce que les pays émergents
vont vouloir avoir quand ils ne l'ont
pas aujourd'hui des choses aussi simples
que l'énergie je vous ai parlé de
l'électricité l'alimentation parce
qu'ils ont encore un million d'êtres
humains un milliard d'êtres humains des
routes dans des dans un continent comme
l'afrique est encore des problèmes
absolument majeur qui font que des
fermiers n'arrive pas à aller au marché
régional pour vendre leurs produits
les routes donc il enfin l'éducation et
je voulais dit pour nous entre autres
bien sûr pour les émergents c'est
important les investissements qu'ils
font dans ce domaine là son fabuleux et
pour nous on est dans une situation où
vous le savez nos universités nos cégeps
doit vivre chaque année avec des
diminutions de leurs budgets c'est une
catastrophe pour les générations à venir
au québec parce que justement on a une
avance et qu'il faut à mon avis la
conserver si on veut
alors je terminerai ce petit tour
d'horizon de l'avenir en vous disant
essaie des choses extrêmement simple que
vous savez sûrement mais quand on voit
l'avenir on a tendance à avoir peur et
je dis tout le temps si on a peur on est
complètement paralysé alors idéalement
ce qu'il faut faire c'est qu'il faut
s'intéresser aux changements sur la
planète parce qu'ils vont nous affecter
de toute façon qu'on soit entrepreneurs
industriels dans les services en
éducation nos universités par exemple
qui risque de se faire dépasser
il faut ne pas avoir peur de ce qui se
produit parce qu'on serait paralysée il
faut comprendre parce que quand on
comprend on l'a vu avec un olivier avant
on va le voir avec monsieur brossard
quand on comprend on peut innover
on peut créer on peut inventer et puis
enfin il faut avoir le génie dans le
monde qui se développe à la vitesse à
laquelle ils se développent de s'adapter
pour pouvoir gagner sa place
c'est ce que je voulais vous dire